best I can tell even walking around two
broken legs for weeks
when do I go back you ever again land on
those legs ear as bones turn to powder
any other ways to serve your country you
want it to be Special Forces
yes sir why do you want to join the CIA
I'd like to help my country make a
difference in the world the average test
time five hours um don't surf it's been
40 minutes
38 minutes what should I do now whatever
you want the deputy director of the NSA
offered me a new position can you tell
me anything in that I can't find the
terrorists in the Internet hey stop
you're making people very happy thank
you you ready for a little action how
this looks juicy how is this all
possible think of it as a Google search
except instead of searching only what
people in public we're also looking at
everything they don't emails chats SMS
whatever you have a wish people no
Kingdom Snow White the NSA is really
tracking every cell phone in the world
most Americans don't want freedom they
want security except people they don't
even know they've made that for you
are they watching us there's something
going on inside the government that's
really wrong and I can't ignore it
I just want to get this data to the
world I feel like I'm made to do this
and this I don't do it then I don't know
anybody else they can't this is
everything I have they're gonna figure
out what I've done did you access an
unauthorized program the government
knows that we have these documents now
can look into a possible death sentence
by transferring back from this
watch yourself
we are running out of time
you're gonna come for me they're gonna
come for all of you to buy a damn bone
daddy's finder and lion is a who knows
nice fast very high